انهى شركه بيل هليكوبتر قبل شهر عمليه
تسليم اخر طائره من طراز اي اتش 1 زد
فايبر الى قوات المارينز الامريكيه كما
سلمت ايضا الشركه سلاح الجو البحريني اول
طائره من اصل اثنتي عشره طائره من نفس
الطراز تم التعاقد عليها في عام 2018
[موسيقى]
الشركه تتفاوض ايضا مع دول اخرى مهتمه
بهذه الطائره التي تعد احدث ما وصل اليه
برنامج الاتش 1 للطوفات الهجوميه والتي
خضعت الكثير من برامج التطوير كما حققت
نجاحا كبيرا على مدى سنوات لكن لا سر نجاح
تصميم هذه الطائره وما مميزات الطراز
الحديث منها وهل تم التغلب على المشكلات
التقنيه التي واجهتها في الماضي ام لا هذه
اسئله نطرحها على نائب رئيس شركه بيل
برنامج الاتش 1 مايك همم
مستر مايك اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتا ما هي
الميزه التي جعلت طوافه الاتش 1 مميزه
واثبتت نفسها على مدى 70 عام
واوقات
والتحديثات على مدى 60 او 70 عاما الماضيه
كما تعرف فان سلسله مروحيات اتش وان تعود
للسنوات طويله ومع كل نموذج من نماذج هذه
الهليكوبتر استمرت شركه بيل والجيش
الامريكي في تحسين قدراتها
والنسخه الاحدث من هذه الطوافه هي طائره
النقل يو اتش 1 ومروحيه اي اتش 1 زد
الهجوميه التي اثبتت جدارتها على ساحه
المعارك الحاليه ولديها اكبر عدد من
القدرات فيما يخص تشكيله الواسع من
الاسلحه التي يمكنها حملها كما انها تتميز
بقدره صمود عاليه في ساحه المعركه وايضا
قابله للصيام
تمتلكان خواص مشتركه بنسبه 80% مما يساعد
على تقليل التكلفه اللوجستيه الا ان
مروحيه اتش وان زد على وجه الخصوص تحمل
تشكيله واسعه من الاسلحه وهي الاقل تكلفه
من بين المروحيات الهجوميه الحديثه في
جميع ارجاء العالم
مستر مايك يعني صيانه الطائرات الهليكوبتر
هي مكلفه جدا لكن كيف تقارن عمليه صيانه
طائرات الاتش 1 بمثيلاتها من الطائرات
الهليكوبتر الهجوميه الاخرى
هي انها حديثه جدا ومتكامله فهناك الكثير
من المعلومات التي بوسع هذه الطائره ان
تساعد في تشخيصها ذاته لدينا مختصون في
الصيانه على متن المروحيه بامكانه من
الاستفاده من البيانات التي ترسلها
المروحيه من اجل المساعده في التعرف
واصلاح اي احتياجات من دون القيام
بالعمليات التقليديه التي تشمل مقاربه
التجربه ومحاوله التعرف على المشكله ففي
الطائرات التناظريه على سبيل المثال سنرى
تدهورا في مستوى الاداء نبدا بعده بازاله
واستبدال المكونات بتسلسل معين للتعرف على
اي نشاط صيانه سيحل المشكله اما توافق اي
اتش 1 زد وكذلك يو اتش وان واي نظرا
لانظمه الطيران الالكترونيه المتكامله
فلدينا القدره على استخراج البيانات من
طائره ودقه في تحديد الخطوات التي نقوم
بها مما يقلل في الختام التكلفه على
الوحده العسكريه التي تعمل فيها المروحيه
اا مثل مايك مؤخرا ظهرت الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات بشكل كبير برايك كيف اثرت هذه
الصواريخ على دور طائرات الهليكوبتر وكذلك
طائرات الاتش 1 ما الحلول الدفاعيه التي
تمتلكها ضد هذه الصواريخ الصواريخ المضاده
للطائرات
شكرا هذا سؤال عظيم اعتقد ان العامل الاهم
هو الامن العملياتي بلا شك الوحدات التي
تستخدم هذه الطائرات لديها خطه عملياتيه
لخفض التهديدات التي تواجهها في ساحه
المعركه كما ان هذه المروحيات مصفحه وتوفر
حمايه للتيار والشخص المسؤول عن توجيه
مدافع المروحيه كما ان لديها قدرات امتصاص
الطاقه في حاله الهبوط الحاده ومجسات
تنبيه مضاده للرضارات واجراءات مضاده
لتهديدات المختلفه مره اخرى لكون هذه
الطائره بنيت من سلاله يعود عمرها 60 عاما
من التكنولوجيا المثبته على ساحه المعركه
فلدينا واحده من اكثر منصات الهجوميه
القادره على الصمود في ساحه المعركه اليوم
مستر مايك بالحديث عن العملاء يعني انتم
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط منذ سنوات لكن كيف
تقيمون وجودكم في هذه المنطقه والان هذه
الدول هذه المنطقه تسعى كذلك لمشاركه
التكنولوجيا ومشاركه الافكار مع الشركات
الكبيره العامله في مجال الصناعات
العسكريه الى اي مدى انتم مستعدون لمشاركه
دول هذه المنطقه مساله نقل التكنولوجيا
ونقل الافكار
البحر
وهذا مشوق جدا كما تعرف لدينا وجود قوي في
الشرق الاوسط والامر العظيم الذي يميز
شركه بيل هو ان لدينا محفظه متكامله من
المنتجات التي تشمل مروحيات التدريب
الخفيفه وصولا الى طائرات النقل الكبيره
والهجوميه وكل شيء في ما بينها مثل
الخدمات الطبيه الطارئه وطائرات النقل
الشخصيات البارزه بالتبني تشكيله رائعه من
المنتجات واعتقد ان هذه ميزه فريده وقيمه
في سوق الشرق الاوسط كما تعرف نحن نقوم
باستمرار بتقيم الشركات المحتمله التي تصب
في مصلحه الطرفين والامر الفريد في مثال
مملكه البحرين
وهم يتعلم من خبراءنا العاملين على المنصه
وبذلك تحدث عمليه تبادل معرفه بشكل كبير
بهذا الشكل نحن نقيم الشركات المحتمله
باستمرار عندما يكون لدى العميل مصالح
كبيره في طائرات سرب فنحن مستعدون للتشارك
مع الدول عندما يكون ذلك منطقيا